when did data science come into its own
as a specialization in a big data world
the explosion and data quantity has
spurred the need for a domain dedicated
to the analysis of this huge volume of
data entered data science the term data
science has emerged in recent times
carving out a new area of specialization
to help organizations make sense of the
vast amounts of data they collect today
data scientists are in high demand and
are also highly respected why armed with
deep knowledge of data analytics tools
and the industry data scientists are
adept at applying principles of data
analytics to solve business problems by
leveraging hard data as a data scientist
it will be your job to provide insights
by analyzing the data and offer
solutions and ideas for improvement
organizations sounds exciting doesn't it
to become a good data scientist you need
to have a basic understanding of
business and be familiar with
statistical techniques and current tools
to analyze business data including new
technology that can keep pace with the
ever-increasing volume of data iPhone is
one of the most widely used technology
in this domain so what does Python have
for data science python is an
interpreted dynamically typed language
with the precise and efficient syntax
and is renowned for its ease of use to
analyze visualize and present data
Python has an extensive library with
built in modules providing easy access
to system functionalities which not only
improves accessibility but also provides
standardized solutions for everyday
programming challenges by taking away
platform specific requirements and
replacing them with platform neutral
api's modules in python libraries
encourage users to make programs
portable
why should a data scientist use Python
apart from being an open source
ecosystem Python and most of its
incredible libraries our platform
independent so you can run this notebook
on Windows Linux or OS 10 without a
change python is part of the winning
formula for productivity software
quality and maintainability at many
companies and institutions around the
world python is one of the leading
technologies used widely in academic
circles and industries because of its
flat learning curve still not sold on
Python then here's some proof
case study forest watch calm a weather
report accuracy rating service is a
hundred percent Python solution using it
in all its competence the front-end
back-end as well as the performance
critical portions Python was chosen to
develop the solution as it comes with
many standard libraries useful in
collecting parsing and storing data from
the web Python is impressive as an
object-oriented rapid application
development language one of pythons key
strengths lies in its ability to produce
results quickly without sacrificing
maintainability of the resulting code
because of the clean design of language
refactoring the Python code was also
much easier than in other languages
moving code around simply requires less
effort forecast watch comm was made
possible because of the ease of
programming complex tasks in Python the
rapid development that Python allows the
east to analyze and represent data in a
simple and visually appealing style
market potential so how does the future
look for Python as the tool for data
science according to Katie nuggets 46
percent of all the data science jobs
list Python as the skill required second
only to SQL according to a survey by the
Association for Computing Machinery
ACM posted on Java Worldcom Python has
surpassed Java as the top language used
to introduce us students to programming
and computer science
projected skill gap there is also going
to be a huge demand for data scientists
who know Python McKinsey & Company a
trusted advisor and counselor for many
of the world's most influential
businesses and institutions projects
that by 2018 the demand for data
scientists who know Python may surpass
supply by perhaps sixty percent making
Python a must know scale for data
scientists forbes.com mentions that the
demand for Python programmers in big
data related positions increased by
ninety six point nine percent and twelve
months
simply learns data science with Python
training is designed to ensure that you
are ready for any assignment in data
analytics and you know what you will
also get to work on real-life industry
projects spanning over three months to
get that vital hands-on experience
you're looking for apart from this you
will also learn how to set up a Python
distribution in different operating
systems master all the Python libraries
and acquire an in-depth understanding of
machine learning techniques and natural
language processing with Python
the course flows as follows you start
with an introduction to data science and
data analytics and statistical concepts
and business applications continue on to
Python environment setup then the Python
libraries numpy Sai PI pandas
scikit-learn matplotlib you will also
learn about web scraping and python
integration with hadoop once you've gone
through all the lessons the next step is
to reinforce whatever you've learned
with the help of projects and
end-of-course assessments to complete
the data science with python
certification you'll need to complete
any two projects and get them evaluated
by the lead trainer score at least 80%
in the online exam you will receive full
support from the simply learned staff
anytime during the course or while
completing your projects if you have
subscribed for live virtual classroom
training you can attend any of the
ongoing batches and revisit important
concepts to help you with your projects
submit your queries by visiting our
website wwlp.com and clicking help and
support at the bottom of the page or
talking directly to our support staff
with the simply talk and light chat
options
note that the prerequisite for this
course is a fundamental knowledge of
Python don't have it don't worry
subscribe to the Python for beginners
course for free and that's about it go
ahead and begin data science with Python
with the first lesson data science
overview
Hey want to become an expert in Big Data
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos centered up and get
certified in Big Data click here